foreign
I want to talk about what physics can
tell us about our own existence where do
we come from where do we go to how much
do we know and how much can we know and
I've summarized this under the title
existential physics which is also the
title of my new book which will be
coming out in August the entire story of
my new book started at this event in
2018 what happened was that someone came
to pick us up in Hereford and combined
several of us in a car so I was stuck in
a car with some other people who I
didn't know for half an hour and there
was a young man sitting next to me and I
can't remember his name but he he said
he's he's a DJ of kind and he'd be
playing music at an evening event and
asked me what I'm doing and I say well
I'm a physicist and he said oh that's
interesting and he told me he talked to
a shaman who told him that his
grandmother was still alive because
quantum mechanics
and at this point I would normally have
excused myself
but it wasn't an option and so I thought
about it for a little bit and maybe
surprisingly came to the conclusion it's
not completely wrong
and so normally I wouldn't have said you
know I wouldn't have said anything about
it but this question made me realize
that physics does say something about us
just because everything obeys the laws
of nature
um everything lives in space and time
and we're all made of the same matter
and that led me to realize that physics
says something about those really big
questions and it's something that we
don't normally talk about for the same
reason I wouldn't normally have talked
about because we're not comfortable
talking about life and death and
consciousness
so um the idea was born that I would
write a book about those big questions
and how much physics can tell us about
it and the message that I wanted to get
across is that physics isn't just about
balls rolling down inclined planes and
Ohm's law and all that kind of stuff
which you learn at school it's about so
much more than this well it doesn't tell
us what life and Consciousness is but it
does tell us what rules life and
Consciousness has to work with and that
does tell us something so this was the
title I originally chose it was also a
nod of course to this song from Roxy
Music which maybe some of you may
remember which I've always found a
little bit depressing but ultimately I
thought it was a song about determinism
what the C on the tide has no way of
turning more than this you know there's
nothing
and I wanted to say it's true that
everything's made of particles but
there's so much more than this to
physics they are so much more that we
can learn from the laws of physics thing
is kind of missing the point yes we're
all made of particles but look at all
the fascinating things that these
particles can do you know there's some
amazing stuff that comes out of
combining all those particles like uh
Society is culture there are living
beings Consciousness and those living
beings have figured out how to discover
the laws of nature that govern their
behavior so I think that's all pretty
amazing and that's a story that deserves
to be told my editor didn't like the
title more than this he thought we have
to get the word physics into the title
so I had to come up with something what
I came up with is that existential
physics is about those aspects of
physics that concern human existence
where do we come from that concerns the
beginning of the universe what are we
made of that's the structure of matter
what can we know are there limits to
knowledge that come from the structure
of those fundamental laws what can
change and maybe some others so um in
this talk I'm not going to go through
all the question my book because I want
to leave you a reason to buy the book of
course but I have picked some
so when I when I wrote this book
um I noticed that I was constantly using
the phrase for we currently know for we
currently know this for we currently
know this so in the end I just decided
to put this into the preface and I wrote
everything I say in this book should
come with the little asterisks this is
for we currently know and the same is
the case for what I say in my talk
unless I explicitly say it's a
speculation it's just for we currently
know and as it goes in science it might
always be that there'll be more evidence
coming in at some point and we'll
understand a little bit more in the
story would change
okay so I start with the question does
the past still exist which is basically
I think the question that this young man
asked me four years ago so I think the
answer is yes
so why do you think this
well this is really an Insight that came
from Albert Einstein um so Albert
Einstein came up with this theory of
special relativity
um which is based on the idea that time
is a dimension so time used to be some
kind of a universal parameter so we all
shared
the same moment the same passage of time
there was a universal now that we could
all agree on this was in the days before
Einstein and then minkowski figured out
that actually this idea that time is a
parameter a universal parameter doesn't
really make a lot of sense if you look
at Maxwell's equations of
electrodynamics so he figured out that
those equations have a particular type
of symmetry
so it's kind of similar to when you take
a ball
and you rotate One Direction of space
into another and the ball doesn't change
and Maxwell's equations also have a
symmetry if you rotate one dimension of
space into time and minkowski said
there's an easy way to make sense of
this we just combine space with time and
then we can rotate in space time and
that explains why Maxwell's equations
have this structure it's got nothing to
do with electrodynamics it comes from
the structure of space-time but what
does it mean well it took Albert
Einstein to figure out what this means
and his theory of special relativity is
roughly speaking based on these three
starting points times the dimension and
we live in this four-dimensional space
time three-dimensional space one of time
the speed of light is finite and the
speed of light and vacuum is the same
for all observers and I should also have
added here probably but you know this
already nothing can move faster than the
speed of light
and all observers viewpoints are equally
valid
now it's kind of hard to draw four
dimensions uh but um I can at least draw
two so we have only one dimension of
space and we have one dimension of time
this is called a space time diagram and
in a space-time diagram if you just sit
there on your chair
um you just make a straight line up so
you're not moving in space you're just
going forward in time if you move at
constant velocity you make a line that's
tilted at an angle you can't go faster
than the speed of light so the speed of
light is normally conventionally drawn
at a 45 degree angle so those gray
shaded area you can't enter those but
the general curve is like some curvy
line that at any point has to stay below
the speed of light angle so this looks
pretty innocent and all by itself
doesn't really mean anything
but let's look at what the consequences
are of those other assumptions that
Einstein started with there's the speed
of light is finite and that sounds
pretty unremarkable but it has some
interesting consequences so when when
you see and hear me speak you see and
hear what happened a fraction of a
second in the past so if I ask you
am I here now
how do you know
by the time you hear those words
I could already have done something else
maybe I just disappeared well you may
say well come on this is insane of
course you are here now
um but how do you even know what now is
what are we even talking about now you
could say well just look at this diagram
clearly this horizontal line that we can
draw this is now we can just all agree
on this and move on with our lives but
just drawing a line in a diagram
isn't physics right we have to come up
with an operational definition how can
we construct This Moment In Time how
could we measure it
and Einstein tried exactly this with
what he called a laser clock
works like this so what you want to do
is you want to come up with a definition
of now at a place which is not also here
so you might want to know if I am here
now
um so Einstein said you can do the
following you place yourself between two
mirrors and you send a laser beam one to
each side
um sent them out at the same time wait
until they come back if they don't come
back at the same time you know you're
not exactly in the middle between the
mirrors because the speed of light is
constant it's always the same so you
move around until the photons come back
at the same time that you know you're in
the middle
and um
once you have done this you can tell
that exactly in the middle between
sending out the photon and them coming
back the photons must have hit the
mirrors
so you could stand in the middle between
the mirrors look at your clock and say
now the photons hit the mirrors so now
you have a way to tell what happens now
at a place where you are not which is at
the mirrors okay great so we've done it
we seem to have defined a notion of
simultaneity
with this laser clock well here's the
problem suppose you have a friend let's
call her Sue who is flying by in a
spaceship or what have you and she's
doing exactly the same thing so she has
two mirrors uh one left her one writer
she sends out her photons positions
herself until the photons come back at
the same time and then from this she
defines her notion of simultaneity now
you would say this is obviously wrong
because these photons do not meet the
mirrors at the same time
it takes longer for the photon to hit
the mirror in the direction where she's
going so which would be this direction
so point it in the wrong direction so
the mirror is running away from the
photon so it takes longer to get there
whereas the photon that goes into the
other direction is running into the
mirror so it gets there earlier
so for you those two events do not
happen at the same time
okay so she seems to have constructed a
notion of simultaneity or a notion of
now that from your perspective just
looks wrong and to make things even more
confusing if you ask her what's going on
then she would say well you're the one
making a mistake because from her
perspective you're the one who's moving
and your mirrors are running away from
the photons
so this is all pretty weird what's it
mean well it means that in general
relativity and special relativity there
is no way to construct a notion of
simultaneity that does not depend on the
Observer so this entire notion of now is
Observer dependent the way that
physicists phrase it so um
this is pretty mind-boggling already it
takes some time to wrap your head around
but it actually gets worse than this
it's special relativity
um because there are some really odd
consequences from this
so um what this example with the laser
clock shows you is that any two events
that are not in causal contact are
simultaneous for some observers so first
I should explain what what does it mean
for them not to be in cost contact it
means you cannot send any signal from
one event to the other in a space-time
diagram this just means if you draw a
straight line from one event to the
other then the angle of the line with
the horizontal is less than 45 degrees
because that's how we have defined the
speed of light
so um
suppose you have some event that is not
in causal contact with your birth so
this little star
is supposed to be the event where you
were born and there is a supernova
explosion Far Far Away In A Distant
Galaxy which is not in causal contact uh
with the event of your birth well there
is always some Observer for whom those
two events will be simultaneous they
would say they happen now because you
can put the observer in the middle and
then you just have to adjust the
velocity of the Observer until the
photons
T imaginary photos you could say this is
all theoretical physics right would come
back from the mirrors that would go
exactly through those two events
and now the next problem is if you have
two events that are on causal contact
say your birth and your death then you
can always find some event which is not
in closer contact with both
um for example again the Supernova and
now there are two observers for for whom
each
both pairs of events are simultaneous so
what this means is if you are willing to
accept that anything exists now which is
not also here
and you believe that Einstein was right
with his theory of special relativity
you're forced to exit to accept that
everything that some Observer thinks
exists now is equally real and this
ultimately means that everything which
happens somewhere in space-time is
equally real as the present moment
okay so that is a little bit hard to
swallow maybe what's even more
surprising is that this is a completely
standard argument which we learn as
under undergrad students and the first
time we hear about it everyone says
they're like what really
and then you walk around like for
today's thinking this can't possibly be
right but it's that's just the way it
comes out in special relativity
um it even has a name it's called The
Block Universe because the universe just
sits there it's there already we just
haven't seen the future
um basically
now there is a little asterisk that I
have to make here because you've
probably all heard of quantum mechanics
so quantum mechanics is a little bit
more complicated than this but to make a
long story short quantum mechanics is
still compatible with special relativity
so the key argument that I just made
doesn't really change the major
difference in quantum mechanics is that
it has an indeterministic element so you
could say that the future isn't actually
fixed because there are some random
chance in the time Evolution but the
arguments which still go through for the
past which is where I wrote the past
still exists about the future well I
don't know okay so does the path still
exists for we currently know yes that
just comes out of Einstein's theories
get to the next question is actually
quite related to this one can
information be destroyed
and the answer to this is it depends and
I can also explain exactly what it
depends on
so um if you think about what you
learned about physics uh in school maybe
Newton's law you know you have an arrow
and you know the initial position and
the initial velocity of the arrow then
you can calculate exactly where the
arrow will land
this is an example of uh natural law
that we're all familiar with but
actually all the natural laws that we
use in the foundational physics work
exactly the same way we have some
initial State then we have an equation
which is called an evolution law and
from this we calculate a final State we
can also do this backwards so if you
know where the arrow landed and what the
velocity was by which it landed you can
calculate where it came from so those
time Evolutions that we have they're all
time reversible at least in principle so
when I say time reversible I just mean
you can use this law forward and
backwards of course in practice a lot of
things are not time reversible just
because
um they're really really difficult like
if you're mixing better for example
um
it becomes so difficult so quickly that
you cannot in practice ever actually
figure out what the initial state was
from the final state but in principle
you know again this is theoretical
physics uh you could if you knew exactly
where all the single molecules are
located in your bowl you could figure
out what the initial state was
okay so I asked the question like can
information be destroyed
we have to talk about what do we mean by
information what I mean by information
here is just all the data that you need
to specify the initial State and what
happens in all those Evolution laws is
that the information is reconfigured but
it can never get destroyed because in
principle you could always take the
final State and apply your Evolution law
and figure out exactly how it started
this is another reason why the past
still exists in some way you just
rearrange things in a universe you never
actually destroy them
so um yeah so I said this is all
fundamental laws except
there are two things which don't fit in
this pattern so in quantum mechanics we
do have an evolution law which is time
reversible that's called the Schrodinger
equation and we can use this forwards
and backwards but this isn't the only
thing that's going on uh in quantum
mechanics in quantum mechanics we have a
second ingredient uh to what happens in
the universe which is the measurement
update so quantum mechanics everything
is described by what's called a wave
function so there's a wave function for
everything for electrons for atoms and
molecules but also for you and I and in
principle for the entire universe so we
describe everything by this thing that's
called the wave function but the wave
function itself is not observable it's
just a device to calculate probabilities
and so what happens when you actually
make a measurement on a single particle
suppose you have the left probability
distribution for an electron or
something the moment you measure the
electron you know where it is
so suddenly you know with 100
probability where the electron is which
means you have to update your wave
function the moment you make a
measurement now the problem with this is
that once you have made the measurement
you no longer know what the wave
function is that it came from could have
been anything you know maybe
the 100 were Peak with 60 percent
uh or maybe it was just 20 and you just
got lucky there's no way of telling so
this measurement process is irreversible
you cannot tell from the final set what
the initial state was this is
this is one one reason uh why
information could actually get destroyed
so you can't you can't figure out what
the initial state was in measurements in
quantum mechanics do destroy information
if you think that the theory that the
way that we currently use it is actually
fundamentally correct
and there are some reason reasons to
doubt this uh one of the major clues
that maybe quantum mechanics isn't the
final story is that it requires you to
talk about detectors to begin with if
quantum mechanics was really a theory
for the fundamental constituents of
matter then it should explain what a
detector does you should be able to
calculate it instead quantum mechanics
has to assume that you know what a
detector is and that's certainly true to
some extent in practice you know we know
a detector when we see it but the theory
doesn't explain it and so I think this
is the clue that quantum mechanics isn't
fundamentally the right thing and
there's also the the question like if we
have a wave function for the entire
universe well who measures this there's
no one to measure it
um so um those I think are reasons to be
kind of skeptical that the measurement
update is actually the right description
of the physical process but
as I said I'd warn you if if this is
speculation this is just a speculation
okay so the other process uh which might
actually destroy information
um is black hole evaporation so
um
normally the way that black holes are
introduced is you you if you throw
something in it can't come out so it's
forever hidden behind the Horizon
um so you could say well if I take a
book and I throw it into a black hole
then it's gone
but that's not necessarily a problem
because just because you can't access
some information doesn't mean it's been
destroyed you know if I take a book and
I lock it into a chest or something you
can also no longer access it but you
wouldn't say that the information has
been destroyed
so um you could say maybe the same is
going on with black holes but then in
the 1970s Stephen Hawking came and said
well the black holes don't sit there
forever but they evaporate they emit
what's now called Hawking radiation
which is basically completely random
radiation contains all the particles
that we know of in different fractions
and the important thing is that this
radiation contains no information other
than the mass of the black hole but very
few bits so to speak
um and it carries away energy from the
black hole and the entire energy is
conserved so what happens that the black
hole shrinks and it radiates and it
shrinks and eventually it's entirely
gone and the only thing that's left is a
lot of this Hawking radiation which
doesn't contain any information so if
you've thrown in your book into the
black hole the information really gets
destroyed it's a process that's not
reversible and there are lots of
problems with this one is that if you
just take this process of black hole
evaporation it's inconsistent with
quantum mechanics even before you make a
measurement
because as I told you the time evolution
in quantum mechanics the schroding
equation the schroding equation is
reversible yet the time evolution of
black hole evaporation is inconsistent
with this reversibility so something
doesn't match up and then after this
maybe you make a measurement but the
problem occurs already before this
this is the reason why most physicists
currently believe that something is
missing in Hawking's calculation for
example this calculation doesn't contain
anything about the quantum properties of
space and time itself that's because we
don't have a theory for the quantum
properties of space and time that's
normally called quantum gravity so
that's not in the calculation that may
be a reason why the result isn't correct
there are lots of other
Solutions physicists have put forward
that I don't want to go through will
there'll be another two hours or
something
but the bottom line is that we don't
know we believe there's something wrong
with this calculation Hawking himself
actually changed his mind he originally
thought information is actually
destroyed in black hole evaporation but
later in its life changed his mind and
so that actually it comes out at some
point but we can't experimentally test
it
um the reason is that the black holes
that we actually know exist out there in
the universe
they're very massive and the Hawking
temperature is inversely proportional to
the mass so the the heavier the black
hole the smaller the temperature and the
temperature of all those black holes is
so small uh that we can't measure it it
would it takes some hundreds of billions
of years to evaporate
so we can't experimentally test it and
the bottom line is we don't know
so the answer to the question can
inflammation get destroyed depends on
what you believe happens in a
measurement in quantum mechanics and in
black hole evaporation personally I
think the answer is no I think really
fundamentally those two processes
um are time reversible
so then let's talk about the question
how does the universe begin where where
do we all come from and if you read any
popular science news about physics at
all you've probably heard countless
different stories about this my brief
answer is uh we don't know
and um I'll try to explain why why I say
this um so the way that modern cosmology
works is that we use Einstein's
equations for general relativity so
those equations to make a long story
short
um they explain how space-time behaves
in reaction to the distribution of
matter in particular the theory tells us
that the Universe expands uh you've
probably heard of this we've also
figured out that not only does it expand
the expansion actually gets faster
and the the rate of expansion is
determined by the amount of matter and
energy in the universe and so the other
way around you can measure the expansion
you can infer what has to be in the
universe
and this Theory makes a lot of
predictions for example the formation of
structures that based on the
distribution the cosmic microwave
background and the properties of the
cosmic microwave background are the
abundances of the lighter atoms the
retrofit distant galaxies Etc and Etc so
this Theory which we have for the
universe from iTunes theory of general
relativity is pretty good and physicists
are quite happy with it
uh it has a little problem which is if
you take those equations and you
extrapolate them back in time well as I
just said the universe currently expands
so if you go back in time then
everything gets closer together and the
density of matter increases and
increases and eventually it'll be
infinitely large
that's a singularity it's not only the
energy density that becomes infinitely
large but also the curvature of space
and it happens at a finite time at about
13.7 billion years before now and this
is called the Big Bang
actually I should probably add that
physicist
pretty much No One Believes that there
was actually a singularity at the Big
Bang but it's probably just a sign that
the equations break down at some point
so physicists use the word Big Bang to
refer to whatever it'll be that replaces
The Singularity but now remember how
natural laws work as I told you earlier
you have an initial State you have an
evolution law and you get to a final
State now this brings up the following
problem suppose you make a measurement
for your final State as we do in
cosmology so we have a measurement right
now we have an idea how the universe
looks right now then we have an
evolution law and the evolution law
gives us an initial state so we work
back in time this is exactly what we do
if we want to explain what happened in
the in the early universe
well the issue is that you can take any
Evolution law and it'll give you an
initial State and then if you take this
initial State and you apply the
evolution law to it that will correctly
give you what we observe today so how do
we ever know which law is the right law
if there's always some initial site that
you can construct from our observations
well um the answer is that this
Evolution law together with the initial
state has to actually explain what we
observe it has to be a Simple Story to
some extent it's basically Occam's razor
so if you think about what I told you
earlier and all the things that modern
cosmology explains like the cosmic
microwave background and the structures
and so on those all come out of a simple
initial State and the Theory actually
tells you how those different things
belong together like how the formation
of structures and distribution of
galaxies and and their correlations and
so on
hang together with the properties of the
cosmic microwave background this doesn't
work for any initial State generically
you'd have to put a lot of information
in the initial state so it wouldn't be
simple anymore
so what this tells us is that
the key justification for using a theory
for the evolution of the universe is
that it has to be simple it has to be a
simple explanation for the observations
that we have today so what physicists
have done to replace this problem with
the singularity of the Big Bang is that
they have replaced part of this
Evolution law
early in the universe so you take the
normal Big Bang Theory up to a certain
moment in time depends on exactly how
you want to do it then you add a
different Evolution law and you use this
Evolution or to go back further in time
this gives you a different initial State
and can get rid of the singularity and
it can kind of have all kinds of other
consequences
so you change the equations and then as
I said you'd always get an initial state
that then fits together with those
equations to give you uh what we
actually observe and there are lots of
different theories that have come out of
this for example there may not have been
a big bang there might have been a big
bounce so there was an earlier Universe
which contracted and then it didn't go
to your Singularity but it just shrunks
to a very small size and then it began
to expand again there could be Cycles
Roger Penrose for example has a model
for a cyclic cosmology there's an idea
that's called asymptotic silence where
basically the early Universe I was just
sitting there for a really really long
time not doing anything and then
suddenly it decided it would expand this
also gets rid of the singularity there's
no boundary proposal from Heartland
Hawking where you basically get rid of
time I'm entirely so there's only space
four dimensions of space
um something maybe there was neither
space nor time there was just a
pre-geometric face maybe some kind of a
big Network that had to condense into a
form where it would give rise to
something that approximate space-time to
a very good Precision five dimensional
black hole string guests and so on and
so forth it's it's a really long list
but those ideas all work the same way
you change the evolution law
somewhere back in time and then you have
a different initial state
now what's the problem with this
um well as I said a good scientific
explanation must be simpler than the
observation it's trying to explain and
the problem with all those theories
um for the more for the early universe
is that they make a simple story more
difficult
but a good scientific explanation should
be as simple as possible and you
shouldn't add any unnecessary
assumptions no matter how much you would
like there to be a cyclic universe is as
um as LaPlace put it I I had no use for
this hypothesis we also don't really
have a use for the hypothesis of an
infinite number of Cycles it's
absolutely unnecessary to explain what
we currently observe
and so this is why I say all those
stories they're basically
Tales the creation myths written in the
language of mathematics they're mostly
not wrong in the sense that all those
physicists I mean it's not like they're
dumb right they make a big effort to get
a theory that actually agrees with
observations of course I mean there are
some people who argue that this or that
idea doesn't actually fit with
observations but that's a little bit
beside the point
mostly they're trying to actually get
the observations out right
so they're not wrong but we can't tell
that they're right because they just add
this unnecessary structure at a time
where we don't actually have any data so
basically you can't believe whichever
one you like and my fronting colleague
Tim Palmer has stopped this a scientific
it's not that it's non-scientific it's
just that science can't actually tell
you which is the right idea
World signs will be able to tell us
which one is the right uh theories for
the early Universe uh I'm not so sure
I'm pretty sure that we'll be able to
improve over the theories that we
currently use uh they have other
shortcomings than uh the Big Bang so I'm
pretty sure we'll be able to come up
with better models than this but will we
ever be able to figure out how the
universe begin I'm very skeptic because
of this issue that there's just no
justification in science to attach a
more difficult story before a simple one
if the early Universe was very simple
then you can can add all more difficult
explanations before this and we would
never be able to figure out which one is
the right one
so that the universe begin
we don't know and we may not never know
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV